um one of the really sick things that's
happening in the united states is that
instead of everybody coming together
to get beyond the pandemic
uh to encourage people to hey if you
have a reason to go and get tested go
and get tested and let's support testing
and let's grow the number of places
where you can get tested there are
people harassing those going and getting
a coveted test i'm going to play a clip
for you in a moment of anti-vaxxers
coved truthers and other types of
conspiracists in new york city
yelling conspiracy theories at people
who were trying to get coveted tests at
one of these corner pop-up clinics
now we don't know exactly when the clip
was filmed the the clip was recently
released
but from the way people are dressed it
doesn't seem like it's that cold in new
york city now at the same time a couple
days ago it was in the mid 50s in new
york city so this may be very recent or
maybe a little bit older we don't know
but let's take a look at the video and
what you're going to hear if you're just
listening
is people yelling conspiracy theories
and berating people getting tested you
get tested why so you know if you should
stay home and not give this thing to
other people it's a good thing to do and
here are anti-vaxxers and conspiracists
attacking those getting tested shut it
down these are faulty the pcr test
yeah this is what's creating all these
fake numbers and creating more fears
fake pcr tests are creating fake numbers
which are creating fear
i'll i'll address this substantively in
a moment by the way
where's this horrible
quarantine whenever there's an arcade
[Music]
invented
said that the vcr test is not accurate
it's true you guys need to look it up
you cannot use it to figure out if
someone has a disease or not even if
it's positive it's not an individual you
guys listen to the person that invented
your test do you guys listen to the
person that invented the vcr test they
don't even know who made the conviction
wow
they don't know who got the term what it
was
this is adding to fear and propaganda
you're pushing fear and getting tested
leads to propaganda
that's right
and a positive test doesn't mean that
you're sick oh my god there's a
bajillion cases i wonder where all those
bajillion copies
came from a fake test
getting a medical procedure on a dirty
rat infested manhattan street corner
getting a medical
procedure kerry mullis carrie mullis
carrie mullis carrie mullis carrie
mullis carrie mullis pcr maker carrie
mullis carrie mueller all right so you
get the idea obviously police should be
called in these situations um and
there's a bunch of different things to
talk about first of all if you believe
in my body my choice
leave people who want to get a test
alone don't harass them let them get a
test you don't nobody's forcing you to
get a test what happened to my body my
choice but let's address substantially
substantively what they're talking about
because i keep getting emails about this
as well saying the inventor of pcr said
the pcr test isn't accurate let me
explain to you exactly what is the the
truth about this uh because it has been
misstated and misstated and misstated a
pcr test
measures the presence
of
uh certain viral proteins okay
it is true
that i could
imagine that someone coughs on me who
has covet okay
i breathe in some viral proteins and
they are now in my nose
i get swabbed
the swab is tested and it's positive for
viral proteins but
i'm triple vaccinated
my body could be fighting off those
viral particles and the viral particles
thank goodness don't replicate and i
don't get an infection certainly it's
conceivable that if you swab me at the
exact moment where those viral particles
that someone coughed on me are in my
throat
that i get a positive test and i never
get sick because my body fights it off
that's possible what the pcr test
measures
is the presence of that virus
in the body it can't definitively tell
you are you sick with covid do you have
an active contagious infection or
did you have just enough viral particles
in your system to trigger a positive
test and then you didn't actually get
sick that's true
generally speaking the timing of that
specific situation i mentioned is very
very rare and it doesn't mean that pcr
tests shouldn't be used can't be used
aren't of diagnostic value it is true
it is true
that you could have the presence of
virus and not be actively infected it's
a very small portion of people
uh and it's not really relevant
to testing strategy in the way that
these people want it to be
now unfortunately
this anti-testing stuff is actually
spreading
in florida florida has a pretty wacky
surge in general
joseph ladapo
he says it's time to unwind this testing
psychology prioritized by the federal
government you don't need to go and get
ted there's he's saying do less testing
don't be so worried about going and
testing here he is we're going to be
working to unwind the sort of testing
psychology right that our federal
leadership has managed to unfortunately
get much most of the country in over the
last two years right testing problem now
the federal government is making too
many people want to get tested let's
unwind it we don't need tests and we
don't need testing wow what a strategy
by the way have you seen florida's
numbers we need to unwind this testing
sort of
sort of uh planning and living one's
life around testing
without it we're gonna be sort of stuck
in the same cycle
so you know it's really time for people
to be living to uh you know to make the
decisions they want regarding
vaccination yeah to enjoy the fact that
many people have natural immunity there
you go uh
oh man meanwhile florida you'll be told
florida is doing great florida
hospitalizations are up 200 percent even
if omicron is indeed less severe on a
case-by-case percentage basis as we
believe it is
florida with a skewing older population
does see plus 200 percent in terms of
hospitalization so a lot of
horrible backwards things going on with
something as benign
as testing and that does not bode
particularly well let me know what
you're seeing in your community find me
on twitter at deepakman
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 5 star reviews
and best of all if you don't love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because they stand behind their
product you've got nothing to lose by
giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 percent off and free shipping when
you go to 4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video